Traducteur: Elise LECAMP
Relecteur: eric vautier
(Applaudissements)
Bonsoir tout le monde,
merci d'être là pour nous toutes et tous.
Quand Béatrice Duboisset m'a proposé
d'intervenir pour le TEDx sur la mixité,
un père musulman, une mère juive,
une origine sociale modeste,
un chemin de parvenue
de petite bourgeoise parisienne,
je me suis dit : « Bon, c'est pour moi ! »
J'ai gardé mes notes avec moi
parce que je suis émotive,
le seul problème est que j'ai du mal
à prendre la parole en public
et en plus ce matin, en bonne juive,
je me suis réveillée avec 39°C de fièvre.
Je vais vous demander
un petit peu d'indulgence.
(Applaudissements)
Merci.
Comme je disais, j'ai été élevée
dans une cité à la Courneuve,
où bien que la mairie communiste
se soit bien occupée de nous,
je me faisais souvent un peu chier.
J'étais fille unique.
Et puis je n'avais pas 14 ans,
j'avais plutôt 8-9 ans,
j'ai découvert Babcock,
Ce sont d'anciens entrepôts
reconvertis en bibliothèque.
Je suis rentrée dans la bibliothèque et ai
découvert « Pot-Bouille » d’Émile Zola.
« Pot-Bouille »,
ce sont les Rougon-Macquart.
Et là, je découvre que les riches
peuvent être pauvres.
Je découvre un autre monde.
La richesse de façade,
derrière les façades haussmanniennes,
il peut y avoir de la pauvreté humaine.
Ça y est, j'étais mordue.
Comme l'a dit Arnaud,
j'ai plongé dans la littérature.
C'est gratuit, c'est silencieux,
c'est pas cher.
Je me suis mise à dévorer les livres.
Comme à quelque chose, malheur est bon,
travaillant bien à l'école,
aimant les livres,
l'ascenceur social s'est naturellement
ouvert devant moi.
Je suis montée :
bons résultats au bac,
désectorisation,
Sorbonne,
Maîtrise,
DEA,
DESS.
Ce que j'oublie de mentionner,
c'est que ma première année de DEUG,
j'arrive, et là,
il y a une fille de ministre,
la fille de Chevènement,
pour ne pas la nommer,
(Rires)
qui me dit :
« Tu as quand même un phrasé particulier,
t'es vraiment une fille des rues. »
C'est vrai que j'arrive de la Courneuve,
tous les soirs j'y rentre,
Je fais mon trajet en RER,
à pied, en métro.
Le trajet est long, de la Terre à la Lune.
Et là,
je lui mets une droite.
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
Vous me croirez ou pas,
la fille Villeroy&Boch,
qui était en DEUG de lettres avec moi,
qui s'appelait Juliette,
très sympa,
elle était anorexique comme moi,
donc ça nous faisait des liens,
elle vient vers moi et elle me dit :
« Fais très gaffe : les pauvres,
ça cogne avec les poings,
mais les riches avec les avocats. »
Je me suis dit, à ce moment-là,
que la mixité sociale,
ça ne serait pas pour tout de suite.
Je continue mes études.
DESS, DEA, Wonderbra.
Stagiaire dans la pub,
assistante de Frédéric Beigbeder,
pour ne pas le nommer,
j'ai décidé de balancer
tout le monde ce soir.
(Rires)
On vient me voir et on me tend
une annonce qui dit :
« Look at me in the eyes
and tell me you love me. »
Regarde-moi dans les yeux
et dis-moi que tu m'aimes, Wonderbra.
On me dit : « Toi la stagiaire,
tu fais des lettres,
traduis-nous ça en français. »
Je n'étudiais pas l'anglais,
mais pourquoi pas ?
Et là, je dis : « Regardez-moi
dans les yeux, j'ai dit les yeux. »
Prix internationaux, à Cannes, etc.
Évidemment, je n'ai pas la récompense,
je retourne finir mon doctorat.
Mais j'entame une carrière
dans la publicité,
parce que le patron - Pascal Maury -
de l'agence TBWA à l'époque,
monte FCB et me dit :
« Je te donne
10 000 fr. par mois
pour venir faire des petites phrases
de rédactrice. »
Pour moi, 10000 fr. par mois,
moi qui étais boursière, c'était le Graal.
Je cesse mon doctorat,
je commence une carrière dans la pub.
Je raconte ça dans mon livre :
« Papa was not a Rolling Stone ».
Je l'ai adapté au cinéma.
J'ai raconté dans ce livre
et dans ce film,
que j'ai quitté la pub à l'âge de 39 ans
après un divorce, un burn-out,
une garde alternée non voulue...
J'ai commencé à faire
ce dont j'avais envie,
c'est-à-dire raconter la vie
de mes contemporains,
raconter quelque chose
qui me tient à cœur :
qu'est-ce qu'être un citoyen français,
une petite française de banlieue
dans la France d'aujourd'hui ?
Le livre a du succès, le film aussi.
Et puis, récemment,
depuis un an à peu près,
je suis régulièrement invitée
par des mairies,
dernièrement à Lyon et à Grenoble
pour projeter mon film dans des salles
et ensuite animer des débats.
Là, je découvre dans les quartiers
populaires de Lyon,
un monde fait de favelas,
- on ne peut pas appeler ça autrement -
avec des enfants qui sont
complètement déconnectés de l'école,
trois-quarts des foyers
qui sont monoparentaux.
Et puis une désaffection de tout ce qui,
moi, m'a tenue debout :
les valeurs de la république.
Je prends mes notes.
Je commence à discuter avec ces jeunes,
j'ai animé beaucoup de débats,
c'est pour ça que
je vous en parle ce soir.
Là, on me dit :
« Il n'y a pas de boulot,
la France, c'est de la merde,
les Juifs sont riches, les Noirs puent,
les Arabes, ils sont tous voilés,
ils vont tous nous crever. »
Tout le monde en avait après
tout le monde en fait.
Je me dis : « Merde. »
Alors je commence à raconter :
« Moi, j'ai grandi dans les années 80...
- Ouais, comme ma rem !
(Rires)
- A une époque où la publicité
chantait des chansons,
où on avait des mains jaunes,
'Touche pas à mon pote'
les filles non voilées
mais on s'en foutait,
on faisait le ramadan, kippour,
on se mélangeait.
On envoyait des sacs de riz en Afrique,
sans savoir s'ils arrivaient.
En tout état de cause, ça circulait.
On allait les uns vers les autres.
Ce n'était pas parfait,
la vie à la Courneuve,
ce n'était pas le Club Med.
Mais quand même et ça,
je l'ai raconté dans deux livres
on a quand même bien ri,
et surtout on allait
les uns vers les autres.
J'ai discuté avec ces jeunes-là,
j'ai discuté avec des élus locaux
et là, les élus locaux me disent :
« Vous accrochez pas mal les jeunes,
que pourriez-vous proposer
pour que les gens
aillent les uns vers les autres ?
- Je ne sais pas, je ne suis pas
le Messie, je n'ai pas de solution.
Déjà, si on commençait à partager,
et puis merde,
pourquoi ne pas s'appuyer sur
ce que le pays a de magnifique :
les valeurs de la république ? »
La France, c'est quoi ?
Je voyage dans le monde entier,
je voyage beaucoup.
La France, c'est la CMU,
l'aide médicale universelle,
c'est un cas unique au monde.
N'importe qui, ça date de Napoléon,
qui traverse le pays peut
se faire soigner gratuitement.
La France, c'est quoi ?
C'est pouvoir étudier gratuitement.
Et mieux, un jour à New-York quand
je disais qu'on me payait pour étudier,
on ne m'a pas crue.
J'avais 3 000 francs par trimestre,
2 900 francs par trimestre
pour aller étudier à la Sorbonne,
et pendant longtemps.
J'essayais d'expliquer ça aux jeunes.
La solution que j'ai soumise,
je ne sais pas si elle est bonne,
il faut commencer à se réapproprier
le drapeau qui fait l'unité de ce pays,
sa mixité justement,
cette mosaïque de cultures, de langues
parce qu'on a tous des origines
plus ou moins diverses et bigarrées,
de cuisines, de régions.
La France en soi est un pays mosaïque.
La France en soi est un pays tout petit
où il y a tous les paysages,
où historiquement, il y a
plusieurs langues qui cohabitent.
J'ai évoqué ce truc-là.
Pourquoi ?
On m'a dit : « Oh la la, Marine Le Pen. »
Eh là non ! Là j'ai paraphrasé
Romain Gary et j'ai dit...
Attendez, il faut que je me souvienne...
« Le patriotisme, c'est l'amour des siens.
Le nationalisme,
c'est la haine de l'autre. »
Applaudissez.
(Applaudissements)
Je n'ai plus de salive, donc je reprends
mes notes pour récupérer.
Bien sûr, elles sont dans le désordre.
Ma solution, c'est ça,
c'est une solution un peu béta :
je pense que nous les mamans,
et même les papas ici,
on a ce devoir de redonner
les valeurs de la patrie à nos enfants.
Moi je n'avais pas de père,
Là, vous pleurez...
(Rires)
J'ai grandi sans père.
Mon père pour moi, c'était quoi ?
C'était l'école,
c'est les bourses que je recevais.
C'est le fait que, quoi qu'il arrive,
je sais à peu près que mon pays
ne me laissera pas tomber.
Mon père ?
Quand on m'a virée de la pub à 39 ans,
en plein divorce avec des frais
et deux jeunes enfants :
c'est 23 mois d'Assedic.
Je n'ai pas vu ça beaucoup sur la planète.
Je voudrais juste qu'on rappelle ça
à la jeunesse de ce pays
qui désespère un peu,
la jeunesse des quartiers,
que j'ai rencontrée.
Vraiment j'ai été saisie
par le désamour de ces enfants,
pour leur pays, pour leur nation.
Il y a une petite black qui me dit :
« Attends madame,
moi je vais te dire.
Quand je marche dans la rue,
je suis à Lyon.
Après, quand je monte l'ascenseur,
c'est comme si je prends l'avion,
quand je rentre, je suis au Sénégal. »
Je lui ai dit : « C'est bien,
juste quand tu es dans la rue,
essaye de voir ce que l'école t'offre.
Accroche-toi à l'école !
- Oui, mais je suis noire.
- Tu sais, j'étais dans une cité,
93120 La Courneuve,
c'était chaud aussi pour le CV.
Mais accroche-toi !
Ta récompense n'en sera que
plus savoureuse. »
Pour finir, je voudrais vous montrer
l'image d'une femme.
Elle est née en Tunisie, elle est venue
en France à l'âge de 32 ans
Elle était très attachée à son pays.
Elle est arrivée en France et elle a
embrassé les valeurs de ce pays.
Cette femme,
c'est ma grand-mère, elle a 93 ans.
Elle ne peut pas être là aujourd'hui.
Elle nous a appris, ses 10 enfants,
ses 28 petits-enfants,
pas les arrières-petits-enfants,
elle nous a appris à aimer ce pays,
à le respecter,
à voir ce qu'il avait de beau.
Elle a été récompensée
il y a quelques années
du seul diplôme
qu'elle ait jamais eu :
c'est la médaille d'or
de la famille française.
Je suis très fière d'elle
et je lui dédie mon intervention
à ce TEDx et je vous embrasse.
(Applaudissements)